more content doesn't necessarily equal
more influence some people just want to
put so much content out there we were
coming up and we were studying other
channels and I thought this was the
philosophy and one other channels had
4,000 videos on their YouTube channel in
the business world one of the biggest
names and it's a content creator it's a
brand it's not even an individual it's a
company and it had been creating content
since YouTube first got started I said
why did he only have two 300 thousand
subscribers they got four thousand
videos then I want to watch the videos
and I looked at it 228 views 193 views
673 views 498 views their last 50 videos
one of the videos at 10,000 views and
then I went to the beginning and I saw
they had three videos that had a couple
million views so those few videos that
got a couple million views that they
posted five years ago is the reason why
they have this many subscribers not
because of what they're doing today so
this whole strategy of let me just throw
stuff up on the wall you can't be doing
that look I every single time we take
more time to create content it always
shows on the numbers and the results
every single time if we take more time
to create content it always shows on the
results every single time just look at
the different personalities on YouTube
who get interviewed by different people
and look at the viewership and the
commentary below read the comments below
and you'll be able to say this person
interviews deeper this person same
subject rules for money this person same
subject you know mistakes I met as an
entrepreneur this person same subject
but their views are higher why is it
deeper what's going on here that's
different or is it just let me share
with you how to go become a millionaire
because guess what the word millionaire
does very well when I put it on a title
you've got to get deeper with the
content you're creating so right there
number two control the narrative if you
don't talk about what you believe in
what your views are who you are as an
individual the world is gonna control
who you are because they'll tell
everybody who you are one of the biggest
benefits to that was watching an
interview the other day on when they
asked LeBron about him missing free
throws because LeBrons been missing a
lot of free throws and Stephen Highsmith
came and said LeBron is a courier 73%
free-throw shooter
but 50% free-throw shooter last five
minutes of the game and when it comes
down to the deciding game free throws
he's like 40% and he says LeBrons never
been a big free-throw shooter then his
partner comes out and says in today's
social media world
you can't hide you could in the 80s you
can today so when they asked LeBron what
do you think about your free throw
shooting he says it's horrible I gotta
get back in practice I have to get back
and get at these free throws because I'm
not good at it today 30 years ago he
could get away with that today he has to
explain it because we're living in a
world that if you don't control the
narrative and talk about the things
you're dealing with somebody else is
gonna control the narrative and talk
about what you're dealing with so you
got to share your views on what your
thing my one of the reasons why you
oughta create content